[Musique]
ces deux pilotes se trouve dans le
cockpit d'un boeing 737
ils vont décoller de l'aéroport de
montréal conditions météo points 10
degrés quelques rafales de vent un peu
de poudrerie en 06
ce cockpit en fait est une réplique
exacte d'un vrai mais en partie
seulement puisque à l'arrière se trouve
le poste de l'instructeur
nous sommes dans un simulateur de vol
voilà à quoi ça ressemble de l'extérieur
il doit pouvoir reproduire tous les
mouvements toutes les sensations de la
viande
à l'arrière des pilotes eric a elle-même
pilote commandant de bord mais qui fait
chez ca 1 fonction d'instructrice les
séances d'instruction dure quatre heures
elles sont très exigeantes toujours
commence avec la basse que tout est en
valent quand les décalages mais un point
c'est un d'ajouter alors on commence
avec quelque chose que comme un feu de
moteur
feu de moteur une situation qui des
allemands est probablement un pilote ne
connaîtra jamais dans sa carrière mais
il aura vécu
hervé qu en simulateur
je crois
sacha massot
la compagnie montréalaise cae existe
depuis 1947 elle fabrique des
simulateurs de vol pour la plupart des
avions des grandes compagnies aériennes
elles contrôlent 70% du marché mondial
il ya une très grande chance que peu
importe où vous êtes dans le monde
le pilote qui vole votre avion est sans
doute formé sur le simulateur
fabriqués ici à montréal conçu par des
ingénieurs ici à montréal
pour moi c'est un secret bien gardé on
en est très fier
il y à 300 simulateur dans 70 centres de
formation à travers la planète où c'est
la forme des pilotes
cae est en fait la plus grande école de
pilotage du monde
depuis quelques années on a des écoles
de pilotage par tous et qui forment les
nouveaux et anciens à devenir pire de
langue donc on a vraiment une formation
seront l'appel de cadets à capitaine se
sont complètes et dont les compagnies
aériennes font trait à la recherche
parce que justement pour combler cette
pénurie pire car pénurie de pilotes il y
a les besoins se chiffrent à 300 mille
nouveaux pilotes de ligne dans les 20
prochaines années et 50000 pour les
avions d'affaires ca vient d'ailleurs
d'acquérir tout le programme de
formation pour les avions d'affaires de
bombardier
une bonne affaire pour ces à former des
pilotes plus vite et bien sûr toujours
mieux
c'est le défi nous on est assis sur une
mine d'or ici parce que notre simulation
elle génère autant de données qu'on veut
grâce à ces données et à l'intelligence
artificielle du nouveau logiciel ca rise
on pourra voir en temps réel toutes les
séances de formation de simulateurs dans
le monde
cet élément là il a été fait à kuala
lumpur
la compagnie juin vous pouvez voir ici
donc les détails vraiment
les graves qui sont associés à la
réaction du pilote dans un cadre de
décollage ou un moteur le programme
permet de déceler des failles dans les
réactions du pilote que l'instructeur
souvent ne verra pas ça peut être un
élément pour l'instructeur qui voit
c'est si bon peut-être mon pilote est un
peu trop stressé donc il n'est pas dans
un bon contexte d'apprentissage
un outil qui permettra à erika et aux
autres instructeurs d'améliorer les
réflexes automatiques des pilotes en
formation dans les situations les plus
invraisemblables 100% de l'entraînement
du pilote se fait sur le simulateur de
va donc le premier vol en tant qu au
pied at on s'entend se faire sur le vrai
avion avec des passages en arrière ce
qui témoigne la sophistication
ici la moitié des effectifs de la
compagnie à montréal est composée
d'ingénieurs ce qui est ancré dans la
culture et maintenant on va faire un
milliard de dollars à la recherche et
développement l'innovation a aussi amené
ses à investir dans le secteur de la
santé c'est le même principe
là aussi il s'agit de simulation sur des
mannequins et surtout grâce à la réalité
virtuelle
comment à simuler des accouchements par
exemple dans des conditions parfois très
difficiles pour réagir dont c'est ce que
la simulation de permettre le pratiquent
et de pratiquer le pratiquer un jour tu
vois tu va réagir mais pensez surtout
sauver les leçons pour s'adonner à cette
pratique
le pdg s'attend à ce que les revenus du
secteur de la santé dépasse dans les
années à venir
ceux de l'aviation
[Musique]